Trump did a horrible time on the stand
about that yeah is there video of it can
we watch there's no video it was a close
up close situation but but this is for
the Civil one where he like lied about
the value of his properties and [__] but
they said he did horrible on understand
like they got him in his Fields so he
got like Angry a couple of
times I heard some this is obviously can
we see it is this it's not for public
consumption if it's a close if it's not
inside of federal courtrooms this is
obviously some conservative guy on
Twitter but he was saying Trump wanted
to have some document that could
exonerate him and then the judge
wouldn't rule it and it's all fixed and
it's just so funny how news is just what
you want it to be oh yeah more than ever
it's always kind of been it's been what
they want us to be now it's just
whatever we want to believe let's just
go with that there's an outlet for you
that is true but yeah the judge ruled on
this one before they even started wait
wait what do you mean like they ruled
that there's clear evidence
a fraud they just want to see the level
of which the fraud was so like he
already lost going in and so now they're
just trying to determine how much
Fraud's going on and uh Laticia James
she's going for like a penalty of 250
million and he can't do business in New
York anymore
whoa so that means every single Trump
property thing everything he just going
to so they're coming for his neck yeah
so if he has to give up the Trump Tower
in New York City does he get to sell
that he I don't think he owns it I think
that he just uses his name as uh naming
rights I believe there was a time where
he was owning and developing is that
piece of real estate yeah that's the
piece of real estate in the city
apartment in the three floor apartment
that he has oh yeah and that's coming
under contention a lot because he said
it's 11,000 he said it's 30,000 ft but
it's actually
11,000 oh so he lied about this square
footage in a New York apartment no no no
but live three times the size where it's
like the value of it was the most
expensive apartment ever in New York
City
ever like he lied that
drastically I mean just to get like you
know favorable loans and [__] like that
but like you can't get a loan here's the
thing they're going to go and Survey
your apartment like no bank is just
going to be like I'll take your word for
it no it's if you are cool with the
person who comes and surveys it like
it's an organized situation so it's like
so the surveyor guy also said that yeah
but then that's on the surveyor guy nah
because you're
you're you're putting this down on paper
and then the surveyor comes and that
surveyer works with your company and is
the only guy who surveys all your places
but a bank would never so a bank sends
their own personal one right because in
order to get a mortgage they have to
make sure that the value I think with
Trump they look the other way don't get
I'm sure what he's doing is illegal as
well like trying to bribe that surveyor
is illegal but accepting the bribe if he
is is on the survey illegal yeah but
then them putting down that information
knowing that it's
incorrect I don't know how illegal that
is because what you put down on your
property doesn't make it law like it
needs to be yeah but that's what you're
saying your property is like hey I live
at this place and this is how much
square foot it is so it's a clear lie
for example every apartment in in like a
loft apartment New York uses the
stairwell as part of their square
footage okay it's not the square footage
of your apartment but they include it in
it but once you have the person that's
coming to actually survey the the the
the space for the loan that you're
trying to take out they will measure it
according to their standards and then be
like it's actually not 4,000 ft² it's
3500 F feet so the price per square foot
is based on 35 not four and that's the
thing if it was that small of a
difference it's not but if it's a third
of the size yeah I'm just saying there
are other people that are also
responsible that should go down so he'll
he'll claim it's this much get a loan
and then when it's tax time oh no it's
really this much it's like he just keeps
so if he loses this he still can run for
president the 250 is like he'll be fine
I mean maybe we really don't know how
much Trump is holding yeah that's a good
point he's been exaggerating I doubt he
has less than 250 I don't yes I thought
he has less than 250 but 250 is gonna
hurt and as a as a politician he can get
so much money and if he like if he wins
which he quite possibly could I think
he's just his net worth he's using
campaign donor money to pay his lawyer
fees is a little telling because he's
getting criticism on using that and it's
like he can easily not get criticism if
he just used his own money fact that
you're dipping into that money he like
maybe I just personally think it's the
Trump thing to do is to use other
people's money that's like part of how
he built his so he he might not you know
he might not have the money but I think
he's also like I'm good nobody nobody's
gon to not vote for me because I use the
campaign money to pay my lawyer fees
because I've convinced them this is a
Witch Hunt anyway yeah so they're going
to be very happy with me beating this as
long as I beat it and what's my loss
here why would I use my own money that's
true
yeah we'll see but this one this
election is going to be crazy crazy yeah
have you seen I saw a Breaking Point say
that in like uh Quinnipiac polling or
whatever G uh Kennedy was getting like
24% of the vote which is the most for
any independent ever maybe ever
including Ros R more than the past more
than any and then who does that affect I
think that affects Trump I think it
affects Trump more I think they're yeah
I think that affects trump it does
affect Biden as well though cuz like
yeah the Democrats aren't happy at all
with Biden no like we've seen enough
examples of him being
[__] uh old tripping not all the way
there where it's just like all right you
can't trick us anymore yeah like they
tricked us with the first election but
also this Ukraine war is a disaster yeah
yeah like what an absolute disaster he
can have to debate Biden's going to have
to debate right no well there are two
debates debates whatever it is the
actual for the main election that's
going to be in brutal yeah Democrats are
apparently starting to come out and be
like hey we don't want you to run
there's no way yeah but who else who was
the guy we spoke about
in Tim Scott Tim Scott isn't that what
from Ohio I think charlem said Tim Scott
I don't know like the Obama's oh David
Axel Rod yes yeah sick so for him to
make a statement that like
hey Biden shouldn't run again that's
huge and he said that yeah cuz you know
that's coming from Obama's Kamp wow and
that's the thing I think that there's a
fracture Big Time fracture between the
Democratic party and the Obamas I think
the Obamas wanted to go a different way
than the DNC is going and I think that
was a lot of the attacks on on Barack
and his wife that makes sense from DNC
pardon we're coming from the DN I don't
think it's and listen I'm this is
absolute conspiracy corner like nothing
to prove this I don't know if it's
coming from the Republicans because I
don't know how afraid the Republicans of
are Michelle Obama when she's never even
hinted at running for president zero
interest you got to be afraid maybe you
got to be afraid of Obama's influence
but Michelle has shown tarnishing his
influence let's make him gay let's make
him this no no that's 100% I go I'll
interrupt he's saying the main threat
from the Obamas to still be president is
Michelle who has shown zero interest in
running for President Obama could
influence people to vote one way but
they're not running so why do
Republicans need to tarnish his name I
think they're not worried about Michelle
running I think they're worried about
Obama's influence because like right now
people are doubting Biden but Obama's
influence is so strong still where if he
just says like hey I still trust that
Biden can really do this let me say one
thing on that go go okay like I still
trust that Obama can I mean Biden can do
this maybe it galvanizes at least the
black vote to still come out now here's
the thing great point but the
Republicans want Biden to run more than
anything so if they felt that Barack was
supportive of Biden right they'd go well
don't [__] touch him if they're going
to keep this guy that we know we can
beat in there that's the number one
opportunity and now that's the same
Playbook Democrats are playing they want
Trump to run they they at the same time
of wanting Trump to run we want to
tarnish his name at the St much as
possible so it's like I think that's
what they're doing I was just thinking
that Republicans wouldn't tarnish his
name because he's going at Biden so it's
like well you're there yeah I think
Democrats are like Democrats would be
like this guy's got influence and he's
saying he doesn't support Biden we got
to make this guy look bad so people will
still vote for Biden because Biden's not
giving it up right now CU Democrats
destroy their own you're going to listen
to this batiman who's backing Biden
right now like any way that you can
tarnish like Obama's influence it's
going to hurt Biden if he backs Biden
seems like he's not that's why I'm
saying no no no he is like at the end of
the day like
allir enough they fall all right guys
we're going to take a break for a second
let's face it okay bad habits are hard
to kick we all know this okay plenty of
bad things we picked up we just cannot
let go of it's awful how are you going
to change that how are you going to
change your life well our sponsor fume
is here to help you kick one of the
hardest habits of all time fume is a
natural diffusive device that uses
plants and Behavioral Science to help
you trade out your negative habit for a
positive
one fume is not of Vape there is no
tobacco or nicotine in this thing it's
just a device that is designed to
transform your negative habit into a
habit that will not affect you at all
instead of PODS filled with potentially
harmful chemicals like a vape fume uses
cores infused with plants peppermint
cinnamon for delicious natural flavors I
love the Mint one that's my favorite one
and fumes new version 2 models even
better it's got the adjustable airflow
dial and magnetic and cap your fingers
will always have something to do telling
you is fun to fidget with is great to
drag on it is the truth if you're trying
to break a bad habit fume has got your
back
so the easiest way to stop a bad habit
is to switch to a positive one and fume
is designed perfectly to do just that
it's fumees goal to make switching easy
and even enjoyable they have thousands
of five-star reviews from people just
like you who successfully switched when
other Solutions didn't work so head to
tume.in to save 10% off when you get the
journey pack today the journey pack
comes with three unique flavors and the
new version 2 fume to help you kick
start your positive habits that is TR
f.com and use the code flagrant to save
an additional 10% off your order today
now let's get back to the show I think I
think DNC is they're just what they did
to Bernie I think that they do to B to
to Barack and I think that's kind of
what happened I think they were like hey
Barack we need your help like what do
you think you want to support Biden say
he's doing a good job whatever and I
think Barack was like nah I'm good and
they're like noted no you're gay it
would I think it's that simple it would
have been way stronger than there's
nothing stronger that they said there
his wife's a man and that he's gay and
he came out you only use it jokes I
mean but I'm just saying like the gay
[__] is crazy I get that but at the same
same time nah that didn't really
permeate at least the black community
that much what that he's gay yeah are
you only got one you got to ignore it
you only got one black yeah that's what
I'm saying so it has to be something
like I got to see factual evidence like
he his dick got to be in another guy's
ass you guys can ignore it and even that
we're going to be like he's top that's
not Good's top oh yeah he's
prison I'm telling you it got to be
strong yeah I mean pretty strong when
you admit it I I do think I don't know
if it gets strong think about [__]
guys the gay gay gayest of people yeah N
I think this uh this next presidential
election is going to be probably the
lowest
turnout that is bad for who who who is
that bad for again Democrats Democrats
because Republicans always vote yeah and
Democrats have more numbers but they're
just not as young people don't vote a
lot the Democratic side it's going to be
bad so then Trump wins no because then
you still got RFK put it so then the
Democrats are bolstering RFK enough
where they'll Chip Away Trump's lead but
it won't
affect their ability to Garner enough
votes to win if RFK gets 20% of the vote
then I think yeah I think Biden wins but
that's just such a I don't
that's 15% of that goes the DNC hasn't
really destroyed RFK yet like there
hasn't been a real effort made
to kind of body him or get him out of
there Mr no nox and all that [__] that's
they side yeah I deal with that wait
wait wait wait what do you mean Mr noax
RFK affects conservative yeah yeah so
it's like so I think they're like oh
we're going to use him going I think
they see him like a useful idiot a
useful idiot yeah we're going to build
you up this is great what you're doing
and uh we want you to shave away as many
points as possible probably same with
Vic like they saw Vive starting a trend
and they're like let this guy cook let
him cook we want to take as many votes
away if vivet can get 10% away from the
base if uh RFK can get 20% away from
that's 30% yeah that's all you need but
propping any of the uh what are the
other Republicans that are trying to run
called uh uh caucus candidates or
something like that it's dangerous
propping any of those guys up CU whoever
is going to be Top Dog Trump just be
like you're my running mate cuz right
now um white haired dude he's out yeah
pis power so it's like you don't want to
prop any one of them too high up because
then it's like even though Trump's
record looks a little shaky in the light
he still has his arm around this guy
that you like like the STIs you could
prop up though because he won't take the
santis as a running it doesn't seem like
I think he's too threatened by the sand
I think Trump will do whatever he has to
do to I ALS Trump is threatened by STIs
it's weird he is leaning into this shoe
thing which is absurd and it's funny but
like I thought D santis is is out of the
race yeah was no he bombed his whole
[__] fell fell apart but then Trump
keeps him around by like making fun of
him Non-Stop about these boots as long
as you're still in the debates you're
still in the running but I wonder if
that's just a useful puning back yeah so
he's like I just need some views I need
some clicks I need people talking about
me and not talking about my case I'm
going to talk about this guy who wears
heels yeah and cook this guy and I can't
cook any of these other candidates
because I might need them to run with me
later I do think he can't feel
threatened by you if he wants you to be
VP if you want to be in Trump's Circle
you you can't be a legitimate to
him Pence was the least but Pence well
here's the thing gay Christian was it
Ted Cruz like think about it now though
it's different he can't if he wins this
time he can't run again so the fear of
his vice president being more liked more
loved more appreciated and more popular
than him doesn't really exist because he
doesn't have to re uh he doesn't have to
gain reelection so he can get the most
likable guy who then can be the next
person who's going to be president it's
actually a pretty you're in a pretty
interesting situation as your second
term and having a new VP because you can
have an actual formidable formidable VP
you don't have to have a CALA Harris
like you know what I mean like Biden has
to have an idiot so that people that
don't go oh [__] why don't we just let
Kamala take over for like think about
how bad Kamala is that there's a guy
who's dead and nobody has said well why
don't we let Kamala do yeah not a single
person has said that is that crazy I
thought he did it at the time to get
more black vote of course he did
whatever but now realize I think it's
backfired and that no one likes her I
think if he got booty judge I think we'd
be like yo let that guy run yeah exactly
there'd be pressure at least be pressure
let him do it there's no pressure from
the inside but with Trump there won't be
pressure anyway because he can only get
one
uh term I was I didn't know that I
didn't know if you could run again if
you took the foure break eight total
years but I think it's uh like there I
think uh what FDR did three FDR FDR and
what was the if you're president during
war you're allowed to keep going or
something what was the justification I
don't think there was a no there was
just no
term after oh he was the first person
that and then after him you are correct
on the wartime thing though they did
keep him going cuz it was sort of like
wartime keep same guy in get always two
terms I thought wait this is World War I
always two terms yeah yeah FDR was FDR
is uh Pearl Harbor yeah changing head
coaching season things got to be going
real bad yeah and then I think like
Rover Cleveland or some [__] like won
and then retired for a couple terms and
then came back and then won so he was
he's doing like the Trump thing where
like he was out he was in out and then
he went back in has anybody taken over
what happens if you're like LBJ where
you take over so you're doing it for for
a year or whatever 2 years because
homeboy got merked and
then let's say you win
reelection and then if you went again
for reelection you could do two out of
those four years yeah I don't know I bet
you they they make it two elections but
I don't know so it's two elections and
then if you take over that's a guess
yeah that's what it should be though I
mean it is such a
wild no but what a wild position Trump's
playing it smart he's not in any of the
debates so they can't attack him smart
yeah and now he just has to wait for
whoever's going to be the front runner
from those debates pulverize themi
charlem came to no but I'm saying he's
going to pulverize them in the primaries
it don't matter if heat or not he's
going to win but I think he'll put his
arm around them before that even happens
so that way it's like hey you're voting
for us who's second right now Nikki
Haley yeah she's kind of she's kind of
took that percolating a little bit Jared
polus and
are also in the
DNC getting pushed up nobody cares yeah
I'm just saying I don't even know the
first guy no one Char charl came to uh
my that birthday surprise birthday that
you guys threw thank you so much and he
brought he was interviewing a woman who
a congress woman from South Carolina
South
Carolina